- You're a success every day.
Success is a daily thing,
not a destination thing.
If you can believe it, you can achieve it.
And that never quite rang true with me.
This something for nothing
entitlement mindset
that invades so many people's
lives is a bunch of garbage.
Too many leaders, they're
like travel agents.
They're sending people where
they've never been themselves.
And you want to be a tour guide.
You want to take people with you.
- He's an American
author, speaker and pastor
who's written many books.
His books have sold millions
of copies worldwide,
with some making the New
York Times bestseller lists.
Ink Magazine named him
the number one leadership
and management expert in the world.
He is John Maxwell,
and here's my take on his
top 10 rules for success.
Rule number eight is my personal favorite,
and make sure to stick
around all the way to the end
for some special bonus clips.
- The first thing I want you to know,
that success is not a
destination, it's a journey.
Think of success as a process.
Let me illustrate it
and explain it this way.
If you go to college, you work hard,
and in four or five years,
depending on what kind of
degree you're working on,
and in today's society
sometimes six or seven years,
but eventually it comes
the day of graduation,
and you're all excited,
and your family is there
and your friends are there,
and you're there with your classmates,
you've got your cap and your gown,
and you know that there's
going to be a time
in that ceremony where you're going
to walk across stage and
the president, provost,
somebody's going to shake your hand,
hand you the diploma, congratulate you,
and you're going to
get off the other side,
they're going to have
presents waiting for you,
and they'll be taking pictures,
and everybody will be shaking your hand,
saying, "congratulations.
"Today you become a success,
you're a college graduate."
Now, my friend,
you did not become a success
the day that you got your diploma.
Now, what you did have happen
to you in that ceremony
is you got recognized for success.
The diploma is recognition
of what you have done
the previous four or five years.
You see, you were a success
in your freshman year
when you decided to not drop out of school
like some of your other classmates,
and decided to stick to it.
And you were a success every
time you studied for a test.
time you did a project,
or did a writing assignment.
You see, you're a success
all through school.
You're a success every day.
Success is a daily thing,
not a destination thing.
The day you got the diploma
you just got recognized
for the success that you already were.
Now, that's very essential.
Because so many times,
people have a tendency
to devalue the moment, today.
What they do is they greatly
value the destination.
And so they kind of talk about,
when I get there or if I arrive there,
or when I do that or
when I accomplish this.
And they don't understand
that success is a daily thing.
And I'm here to share with you
that the secret of success is determined
by your daily agenda.
In fact, I wrote a book a few years ago
called Today Matters.
I'm passionate about that book,
because what it does is it helps you,
it helps me to understand
that we make decisions
and then we manage decisions.
And too often we think,
I will make a decision,
for example, you're saying,
"I'm going to make a
decision to be a coach."
Or, "I'm going to make a
decision to be a public speaker.
"I want to be a communicator."
Well, congratulations.
You've made a wonderful decision.
Coach, speaking, good decisions.
But that won't make
you a successful coach.
That won't make you a
successful communicator.
It's not the decision that makes you.
You've got to make the
decision by managing it.
And you manage the
decision on a daily basis.
In other words, what
you want to be tomorrow,
you've got to do today.
You visualize tomorrow.
That gives you hope.
That's your motivation,
and that's your dream.
Nothing wrong with that.
You visualize tomorrow,
but you value today.
What's that mean?
That means that what I do every day
is either getting me
closer to that vision,
that dream, that goal,
or it's really driving
me farther away from it.
You see, every day, we
are either repairing
or we're preparing.
You see, if I messed up yesterday,
guess what I get to do today?
Fix yesterday. (laughs)
In other words, if I didn't
do the right thing yesterday,
what I got to do today
is I've got to repair.
I've got to go back, make amends,
backtrack, put the car in
reverse, put my life in reverse.
I've got to go back there.
I've got to repair.
Now, every day I spend repairing,
I'm not spending preparing.
Well, you see, we repair
when we fail to manage
the decisions that we've made.
We prepare when we, on a daily basis,
manage the decisions that we've made.
So your footprints to success
are really footprints of success.
Because every step that is made and taken,
based upon the goals that
you have for your life,
and you manage those goals correctly,
every step is the progressive realization
of success in your life.
And by the way, oh,
you'll get the diploma.
You'll get the certificate.
But when you get that, you didn't arrive.
It just is another step in preparing you
to reach your potential.
Each one of us should live our life
as if we'll never learn
everything we need to learn,
we'll never be able to
accomplish everything
we wanted to accomplish,
we won't be able to experience everything
we wanted to experience.
We should live our life every day hungry,
understanding that we
are to live until we die.
You see, I think success
can't be summarized
in a flippant degree or program
or diploma or arrival.
I think today, if you
are learning to coach,
if you are learning to speak,
if you're doing the
things that are essential
to the decisions, and you're
managing those decisions,
well, can I say something to you?
Congratulations.
You are already a success.
Now, guess what?
Over time, it shows up.
You've heard the expression.
You maybe even have said it yourself.
You've heard the expression, I'm sure.
I've worked all my life to
become an overnight success.
That's the way it works.
All of a sudden, somebody recognizes you,
all of sudden somebody congratulates you.
You didn't get good at that moment,
you've been good for a long time.
It just showed up some day.
Have you ever heard a motivational speaker
tell you that attitude is everything?
I bet you have.
I've heard many say that.
In fact, they'll say something like,
if you can believe it you can achieve it.
And that never quite rang true with me.
So I began to press the issue,
and I have come to the conclusion
that attitude isn't everything.
Now, I'm not disclaiming or in any way
being disparaging about attitude,
because I think attitude
is very important.
But if anybody comes
up to you and tells you
that attitude is everything,
don't buy into that.
That's not true.
For example, attitude
can't replace incompetence.
If you're incompetent,
you can be very happy,
but you'll still be very unsuccessful.
Now, here's what I do know.
Attitude isn't everything,
but attitude is the main thing
that'll make a difference in your life.
Because I believe that,
I wrote the book The Difference Maker.
You see, that's what attitude is.
Attitude is the difference maker.
You have two people side by side
that you're thinking about
employing in your company.
Both of them have the same background,
the same job description,
education, experience,
I mean, you could almost flip a coin
and say, "I could hire
the one on the right
"or I could hire the one on the left."
But one has a great attitude,
and one has a bad attitude.
Now, who are you going to hire?
You're going to hire the
person with the great attitude.
Why?
Because it was the difference maker.
In areas of choice, you need
to work on your weaknesses.
For example, let's say I am lazy.
That's an area of choice.
I'm not naturally lazy, I'm just lazy.
It's a choice.
So I need to work on that.
Because in areas of choices,
you can make vast improvement
and you can fast improvement.
- [Interviewer] I've never heard
this distinction, by the way.
It's hugely helpful.
- In choices, attitude.
Lets say I have a lousy attitude.
One day I wake up and say this
isn't getting me anywhere.
I've got to have a good attitude.
You can go from a zero
to a 10 almost overnight.
You've seen people and you say,
"my gosh, overnight they
just got good and happy."
You know what I'm saying?
That's a choice.
Vast, fast growth in choices.
In giftedness,
DNA wiring,
your growth is very, very small.
And it's very slow.
So I think, for example,
a person can maybe increase
their giftedness skillset
maybe two numbers.
So if I'm a little bit
above average, I'm a six,
if I really work hard
I can become an eight.
But an eight is powerful.
Eight has a huge return.
So what I tell people is
in areas of giftedness,
that's where you have to
work on your strengths.
If I'm a two at something,
I'm very weak in a skill,
if I worked hard I could
only become a four.
I'd still be below average.
That's what I tell people,
you've got to ask yourself,
is it going to give me the return.
So, in the area of strengths,
you've got to pour yourself into
the things that you're already good at
because that'll really set
you apart from average.
But in areas of choices,
go for those weaknesses.
Because don't you know people
that are highly skills but
they have a lousy attitude
or they're not self-disciplined.
They're never going to get anywhere.
And they're never going to get anywhere
so in areas of choices,
work on your weaknesses.
But in areas of strengths and skills,
just work on your strengths.
Paul Harvey said that you can tell
you're on the road the success
because it's uphill all the way.
And I'm here to tell you,
this something for nothing
entitlement mindset
that invades so many people's lives
is a bunch of garbage.
I can promise you, nothing
that I've ever had worthwhile
did I have just kind of fall into my lap,
like, oh my goodness, I won the lottery.
I know once in a while
people win the lottery.
But basically, the people
that win the lottery,
half of them lose their
money within three years,
the money they won.
And it's because they got money,
but they never changed
the way they thought.
And can I tell you something?
If you have all the assets of the world
but you don't change the way you think,
you'll lose all the assets of the world.
And what I've discovered
in this whole process of trade-offs is,
that every step of the way of my journey,
I have to trade something off.
And for you that are young,
the good news is your trade-offs
will never be easier
than when you're young.
I remember when Marg and I started out,
I think, man, I'd give up everything.
I was a pastor to go in the Ministry,
I gave up everything, and
then I started smiling.
I thought, sure I gave up everything.
I didn't have anything to give up.
I was kid, you know what I mean?
I had a 1964 Ford Falcon
and a U-Haul trailer,
and five pieces of
furniture and life was grand
and off we went.
Here's what I've discovered, Ken,
and I think I want the audience,
I want everyone watching around the world
to know today, this is very simple.
The more successful you become,
the higher the trade-offs are.
You see, we make a mistake
thinking it gets easier.
It doesn't get easier, it gets harder.
And the more you have,
every time you go back and say,
"am I willing to risk that again,"
the more realize, wow,
I'm not sure I am willing to risk this.
And what I've learned is,
the moment I stopped making trade-offs
is the moment that I plateau.
And life is continually
filled with trade-offs.
In your life and in my life.
My expression that I use all the time,
Ken, you've heard me say this,
you have to give up to go up.
When somebody comes and says,
"John I want to be a leader,"
I always ask them the question why.
Why do you want to be a leader?
Do you want to be a leader
because you want a corner office?
Do you want to be a leader because
you like to be in control?
Do you want to be a
leader because you love
to be in the front of the pack?
Do you want to be a leader because
you have a good parking place?
Why do you want to be a leader?
Because leadership isn't easy.
Leadership, a lot of times, isn't fun.
Leadership, a lot of
times, is kind of lonely.
There's only one reason to be a leader.
And that is to add value to people.
And you and I will only
add value to people
if we truly value them.
I have a non-profit organization, EQUIP,
that's trained almost two million leaders
internationally around the
world, and I kid you not,
as I go to developing
countries twice a year,
and I travel internationally,
and I sit down, sometimes
I have the privilege
to be in the office of the
presidents of countries.
And as I watch these developing countries,
the thing that is the
cardinal sin among leadership
so much is that they have
leaders of their countries
that truly don't value the people.
And if you and I don't value people,
we will devalue people.
Number two, if you want
to add value to people
you have to make yourself more valuable.
You just have to get better.
You have to keep growing,
you have to keep learning,
you have to keep developing.
Why?
Very simply.
If you're leading the pack,
you have to be able to give what you have.
And you can't give what you don't have.
And so therefore, you've got
to put a lot of good stuff in
so you can pass it on to others
and share with them and add value to them.
Thirdly, if you want
to add value to people,
you have to know and relate
to what other people value.
You and I have to walk
slowly through the crowd.
We have to listen, we have to care.
You see, great leaders are,
first of all, listeners,
and then they're learners,
and then they're leaders.
They really do take their
cue from the people.
They understand the key of leadership
is connecting with the
people that you lead,
and the only way that
you and I ever connect
is by caring enough to listen.
Number four is very important to me.
When I'm speaking in
the business community,
I always share with them that for them
there are three ways
to add value to people.
But for me there are four.
And I tell them I'll give them the three,
so I'll spend maybe an hour doing
those three things I just shared with you,
talking about how to add value to people.
And then only when I'm
done with the three,
somebody will raise their hand and say,
"John, you said that
for you there was four.
"But you said there's only three for us."
I said, "yes, there's nothing personal,
"but this is about my faith,
"and so I don't really
need to share this with you
"because I'm trying to help you
"and I don't want to cross
boundaries with you."
And everyone will say, "Well,
John, tell us what yours is."
And I'll say, "okay, you can hear mine,
"but don't write it down."
(audience laughs)
"In fact, don't listen."
Because number four for me is,
if I really want to add value to people,
I have to do the things that God values.
You see, the greatest motivational
principle in the world,
the greatest motivational
principle in the world
is that people do what people see.
And too many travel agents,
too many travel agents, they're like,
or too many leader are like travel agents.
They're sending people where
they've never been themselves.
And you want to be a tour guide.
You want to take people with you.
You want to say this is
the area where I've been,
this is the area where I live,
this is the area where I lead,
come along and follow me.
And at level number three,
your leadership begins
to gain credibility,
because now you are fleshing
out for the people around you,
and you are modeling for them
things that they want to see.
And you are starting to produce.
- How would you tell us to
develop a habit of curiosity?
- Well, you know what?
People do look at me
and see me as creative
because I've written so many books.
And I am curious.
But when I started off in college,
in my freshman psych class,
they gave us a test for each
student to take on creativity.
And there were 17 in that
class, I can remember it well.
And I was at the bottom of
the class on creativity.
I mean, I was like number 17 out of 17.
The teacher posted the scores,
and so I saw how bad I was.
And then I really felt bad.
Not only because I wasn't creative,
but I was going to go into pastor,
I was going to go into ministry,
I was going to teach, I
was going to do sermons.
And then I got to thinking to myself,
I'm going to be another boring preacher.
(audience laughs)
That just gripped me.
I thought, this is going to be awful.
I'm going to bore people all my life,
if you know what I mean.
And then I'm going to ask them
to pay while they hear me.
And this is an awful deal.
And so two things I did.
And I talked about it in the book.
One is, I starting filing.
I started taking thoughts and quotes.
And the reason I started doing that is
I thought, if I'm not going
to be good at what I say,
I need to quote somebody that is good.
And so I started filing things
that other people would say,
so I'd go around and I'd
say, "well, Ken said,"
you know what I mean?
And Joe said, and Susie said.
And so then at least I would be
a little bit more interesting.
And that's how it started.
But the big breakthrough I had was,
and this will help everyone.
How many would like to be more creative?
Let me see your hands.
How many of you would like to
just absolutely have an imagination
that just took you to a new level?
How many already have that
because you're on drugs?
(audience laughs)
Here's the key, this'll work for you.
I promise it will work for
you because it worked for me.
I made a major change in my early 30s
from just having answers
and being a leader
that just had to cast vision,
show everybody what I was
doing and where we were going,
and I started asking
intentional questions.
And I became a person, I
ask questions all the time.
Every day I ask questions.
And I have found, just asking questions
will take you on exiting
journeys more than anything else.
You excel in that, Ken.
I've watched you over the years.
You do excel, really, in that.
But for my early years, I
didn't ask enough questions,
and so therefore, I
didn't get enough ideas
and thoughts from others.
So when people say, "I
want to be more creative,
"what's step number one?"
Step number one is ask more questions.
Just go to people and
start asking questions.
It's a amazing what you'll learn.
In Switzerland, there are some mountains
that can be climbed by
people like you and me.
We got to get a little
bit better condition,
but it's not like the
mountain climber mountains
that would be way beyond our skill level.
But some of these mountains
that can be climbed by you and me,
it takes a day to get to the top,
and then you camp up there,
and you come down the next day.
And on many of these places in Switzerland
where you can do that,
about halfway up the mountain
is what they all the halfway house.
Halfway house, halfway up the mountain.
So a group of people starts off
with a guide in the morning,
and about noon, you're kind of tired.
You've been walking now
for four or five hours,
and here comes, you're coming
up on the halfway house,
and it is just a wonderful sight.
Because as soon as you
enter the halfway house,
you can smell the food,
and they're getting
ready for a good lunch,
and you're sitting down,
there's a fire in the fireplace,
and there's nice soft chairs,
you can just rest your
body and refresh your body.
And so the people go
into the halfway house,
they eat and laugh and enjoy,
and just really, really
just kind of take in
that wonderful, refreshing atmosphere.
About an hour and a 1/2 after
being in the halfway house,
the guide gets up and says,
"well, gang, it's time
to put on your gear.
"We've got a hike, we've
got get on up to the top."
This is a fact.
About half the people decide
not to go on up to the top.
They're sitting around the table,
and they just say, "you
know what, go on up.
"You're going to be
coming by here tomorrow.
"You're going to be having
lunch here again tomorrow.
"We're just going to hang here."
And so the people that
want to get to the top,
they put their stuff on,
and they kind of leave,
and the rest of the people stay behind,
they eat a little bit more food,
get around the piano, sing some songs,
get around the fireplace, enjoy the fire,
warm themselves by the fire.
Play games all afternoon,
kind of enjoy themselves.
But about 4:30, quarter
to five in the afternoon,
without anybody saying a word,
the people who stayed
in the halfway house,
they slowly go over to
where the window is,
the big window,
and they start looking outside,
and they start looking up
at the top of that mountain.
And as they look at the
top of that mountain,
they see their friends.
Their friends are now
getting their tents out,
and they're getting ready
to prepare for the night,
and it becomes very quiet.
Very somber.
Because everybody in the
halfway house realizes
the mistake they've made.
They've sold their
mission for a little bit
of comfort for a few hours.
Next morning, down come their friends.
And by noon, they come
into the halfway house.
And when they come in, they are laughing,
they're high-fiving,
they're talking about what they've seen,
where they've been, experiences,
the fact that it was almost
impossible to get up there.
In fact, they had to help
each other get up there.
And how they joined teams and held hands,
and they're just telling
all of these stories,
and talk about the pictures they've taken,
and how they got their group picture
up there with the flag at the top.
And the people who remained behind,
they don't say much.
They just eat their lunch,
and then follow the rest of them down
to the bottom of the hill
where their friends are waiting for them.
Those who paid the price
and went to the top,
who understood now is the
time to reach the mission,
they hug and tell stories and celebrate.
And the others, they just kind of slip off
and get in their car and go home.
Because they realize they're never going
to be what they wanted to be.
They're never going to see
what they wanted to see.
They're never going to do
what they wanted to do.
Because they failed to realize,
when they were at the halfway house,
now's the time to rest and then go on.
Connecting increases your influence
in every situation.
For the foundation of the teaching today,
I want to make sure that we really have
a grasp of why connecting
with people is so vital.
So if you'll go to the very
first sentence in your notes,
the number one criteria for
advancement and promotion
for professionals is an ability
to communicate effectively.
That I do believe.
I think the ability to
connect and communicate
is the number one criteria for success
with your family, with your marriage,
with your children, with your friends,
in the workplace, the
marketplace, in the community.
If you have the ability
to connect with people,
if you can communicate and connect,
not just communicate,
it takes you and literally
gives you an eye,
a decided edge over others in
the advancement of what
we're trying to accomplish.
For example, in your notes,
presidential historian Robert Dallek says
that the successful
presidents exhibit five skills
and qualities that enable them
to achieve things that others don't.
So he's talking about leaders
and presidents and people.
What makes them achieve
better than others?
Here are the five things they do well.
Number one is vision.
Number two, pragmatism.
Number three, consensus-building.
The ability to put together
a team, get consensus.
Number four, charisma.
And number five, trustworthiness.
Being a trustworthy kind of a person.
Now, what is interesting about these five,
these five things that set
the better presidents apart
from maybe the average ones,
four of the five deal with connecting.
Vision is a definitely connecting skill.
The ability to cast a future vision.
Consensus-building, getting
people to work together.
You have to be able to connect to do that.
Charisma, of course.
That's why people follow
the, quote, the pied piper.
And trustworthy.
Four of the five of the skills needed
to be successful as a leader had
a lot to do with connecting.
So let me define connecting,
because that's what
this book is all about.
Connecting is the ability
to identify with people
and relate to them in such a way
that it increases our influence with them.
In other words, we can identify with them
until they say, "he or she understands
"exactly what I know and
what I'm going through."
and we can relate with them until we,
because of that ability,
we begin to increase
our influence with them.
And of course, what do I
teach about leadership?
Very simple, leadership is influence.
I think success, first of all,
is knowing my purpose in life.
As I have watched and
observed successful people,
what I have discovered about them is,
they really have figured
out why they're here.
They really do have their act together.
And knowing their purpose in life
is a stability for them.
So that when everyone else
is rocking and rolling,
and things are a little unsteady,
and people are leaving the ship,
people are kind of
abandoning their causes,
these people, they hold steady
right throughout the storm.
Because they have a true north star.
They truly are focused.
It becomes an anchor in their life
that just holds them steady.
And the anchor is a confidence
based upon a knowledge of purpose.
Someone said that there are
two great days in a person's life.
The day that they are born,
and the day they discover why.
I'm here to tell you,
highly successful people
they've discovered why.
- Thank you so much for watching.
I made this video because
John Fontana asked me to.
So if there's a famous entrepreneur
that you want me to profile next,
leave it in the comments below
and I'll see what I can do.
I also love to know
which of John Maxwell's
top 10 rules had the biggest
impact on you and why.
Leave it in the comments, and
I will join in the discussion.
Finally, I wanted to
give a quick shout out
to Rhonda Young.
Rhonda, thank you so
much for buying my book.
It means a lot to me.
For those of you watching,
if you want your chance at a
shout-out in a future video,
make sure to pick up a copy of the book,
and then email in your receipt
so I can keep track of you
and give you some acknowledgement.
Thank you guys so much for watching.
Continue to believe, or
whatever your one word is,
and I'll see you soon.
(thunder roars)
- I've never met a person
who was not successful
that didn't have a great amount
of self-discipline within their life.
Self-discipline and being able to perform,
and being able to keep
your life on schedule
and being able to keep commitments
and promises and meet deadlines
is essential to success.
None of us, none of us
can afford to have a life
that is controlled by someone else,
or a life that is basically
controlled by our emotions.
I learned many years ago that
there are two kinds of people.
There's the type of person who says,
"I'm going to wait till I
feel like it before I do it."
And then there's the person who says,
"I've got to do it so
that I feel like it."
One will never get anything done
because they're still waiting
to feel the moment to move,
and the other person
says, "no, I need I move,
"and then I will begin
to feel the moment."
Assigning yourself discipline is essential
in your life and in my life
if we're going to get things done.
So I have a challenge for
every one of you this weekend.
The challenge is simple.
As you go through your weekend,
and sometimes it's kind of, hopefully,
an easier time of your week,
ask yourself, am I practicing
self-discipline in my life?
Am I doing the things that I should do
because I need to do them,
or am I kind of waiting
to feel the moment?
Do like our friends Nike say, just do it.
- How do find our
personal Kurt Kiermaiers?
Somebody who can really
speak into our lives
and change our trajectory?
- Well, I can't take credit for it.
I went to a seminar that
Kurt was teaching on success,
and when he finished
teaching I went up to him
and introduced myself.
And I asked for an appointment with him.
And he came, then the Lancaster
to the Holiday Inn for breakfast,
and we had that breakfast
meeting that did change my life.
And then I never saw
him again from that time
until my 65th birthday
when my staff brought,
I never had seen him.
I talked about him, and talked about,
on my 65th birthday, when we
were having a party together,
they brought him into the room.
And I hadn't seen him for 40 years.
I just wept.
And I thought, you know.
But I think the key was,
when I went to hear him,
and he began to speak to my
life about being successful,
I kind of broke out of a barrier
and I went to introduce
myself, and then I asked,
could I take him to breakfast
and could I learn from him.
And I think the key is,
once you see somebody that is helping you,
be bold and ask them, "can
I take you to breakfast."
And by the way, here's a thought.
Buy the breakfast, okay?
(Ken and audience laugh)
Just don't go and say, "hey, how about
"buying breakfast for me?"
But just, I took that step,
and I've always been
glad I took that step,
and I've thought to myself, you know what?
If I wouldn't have taken the step,
then I probably would have
never had that relationship,
and never maybe would
have asked that question,
and never would have this seminar
or would have written the book.
So I think once you see somebody
that you think can really help you,
take the initiative and step right out.
Something magical happens when you begin
to understand the most appreciable asset
you have in any organization
is the people of that organization.
And you begin to commit yourself
to develop the people
in that organization.
Because how do you grow a company?
You grow a company by growing people.
And when you grow them, they
increase their capacity.
And when they an increase their capacity,
they begin to increase the capacity
of what you can do and
what you can accomplish.
Let me just share with you quickly
three thoughts on developing
people, just very quickly.
Number one is, the key
to developing leaders
and the key to developing
good people is in recruitment.
The better person you bring in the door,
the higher odds that you
can do well with them.
I remember having lunch
one time with Lou Holtz,
and Lou Holtz said,
"John, I've had bad players
on my football team,
"and I've had good players
on my football team."
And he said, "just to be honest with you,
"I'm a better coach with good players."
(audience laughs)
Of course he is.
Let me tell you something.
80% of your success of equipping
people to be successful
is in the front door on who you bring in.
I wish I had time to develop that for you
because what happens is,
unless you and I have a clear picture
of what we're looking for,
we don't know when we see it.
Happens all the time.
People come to me and say,
"John, I'm looking for some
leaders for my company.
"What do you suggest?"
The first question I ask is
what does a leader look like?
Give me the characteristics,
give the qualities.
Please, please, paint a picture for me.
What does that leader look like?
Because you got to have that clear picture
so that when you see that person you know
they're the one that you want.
Recruitment is key.
Number two is positioning.
The ability not only to bring
the right person in the front door,
but also put them in the right places.
Collins would say get them on the bus.
Get them on the right seat.
And position is huge.
And what I've discovered
is that successful people
have always positioned themselves well.
When you see a successful person,
they're successful because
what they have done
is they have found their strength zone
and they've found their niche,
and they stay right in that sweet spot.
And they just work that sweet spot.
You've never heard
anybody being interviewed
that was successful that you
came up and your interviewed
and they said, "well,
the secret of my success
"is that I never discovered
what I was good at."
Or, "the secret of my success is
"I've just worked on my weakness."
No, no, they're always in their strength.
They've already discovered
what they're good at.
Now, successful people have
discovered what they're good at.
Successful leaders discover
what other people are good at.
Successful people
position themselves well.
A successful leader position
the other people well.
And at level number four,
that's exactly what happened.
The leader is always
looking at the people,
observing, watching.
Just like last week, I went
back to my first school.
I graduated from Ohio Christian University
in the little town of Circleville, Ohio.
And it's a little school.
I go back every year and I
give them a day to speak,
and they get all the
proceeds, and keep the money.
And so because I grew up in that town,
I told one of my friends
that play ball with me, Tim,
I said, "Tim, let the ball players,
"let the team know, let some
of my high school kids know
"that I'm going to be in town,
"and let's have a dinner afterwards."
And we had over 50 people came together.
I hadn't seen many of my high school mates
since I graduated from high
school clear back in 1965.
And we had a wonderful time.
We laughed and talked and
told stories for two hours,
and Coach Neff, our basketball
coach, he came back.
I hadn't seen him for years.
And when I saw him, I thought to myself,
and I thought of back in those
scrimmages in basketball,
because the first scrimmage every year,
Coach Neff would take the first team,
and he'd say, "now, I'm going
"to let you play the second team,
"but there's one condition.
"The first team is not going
to play their position."
And he'd take Doug Roth, who is 6'8"
and put him out at point guard.
I remember he stuck me
one year under center.
And he put all the first team players
out of position on an offense.
But he let the second team
play in their position.
And the second team always
beat us in the scrimmage.
Why did they always beat us?
Because, and then he would
stop and he would say,
"let me just explain something to you.
"No matter how talented you are,
"if you're out of position,
"you'll never reach your potential."
What was Coach Neff teaching us?
He was coaching us and he was teaching us
that it's key to get positionally correct.
And it's also, as the leader,
key to get your people
in the right position.
And at level number four,
that's what happens.
At level number four, you recruit well,
you position well, and
then you equip well.
Now you take them and say, okay,
I understand what their strength zone is.
I understand what their gift in this is.
Now I'm going to equip them.
I'm going to come along side of them
and I'm going to develop them
and I'm going to train them.
And I use a very simple,
for years, for many, many years,
a simple five-step equipping process.
It really works.
Step one, I do it.
It's that simple.
You can't teach somebody
what you can't do yourself.
We may teach what we know,
but we reproduce what we are.
So if you're going to reproduce yourself,
you got to be it yourself.
So the first step is I do it.
Step two is I do it and you're with me.
I take you with me.
Now we're going to spend today together,
I'm going to be your mentor,
I'm going to be your coach,
you're going to watch me,
you're going to observe me,
you're going to see me
in different situations,
we're going to make sure that it works.
You're going to be able
to ask me questions.
Step three is, now we turn it.
And I hand the ball off to you.
Now, in step three, you do it.
You do it and I'm with you.
Now I'm watching you.
I'm tweaking you and I'm
helping you to get better.
I'm just really fine-tuning you.
Step four is you do it.
You just do it.
You don't need me anymore,
you know how to do it.
You do it, and you do it well.
And many times, people
think that equipping stops
at step four, but it doesn't.
There's one more step
that's absolutely essential.
Step five is you do it
and somebody's with you.
You're never really
trained to equip somebody
until they can multiply themselves.
That's where all compounding is.
That's where all
compounding of time, money,
influence, the whole process.
Compounding begins when
you can train somebody
who has trained somebody.
I know that well because 14 years ago
I started a non-profit
organization called EQUIP
that is now the largest
leadership organization
in the world.
And we trained and equipped
over three million people
in 154 countries.
And the key to that is
we don't train anybody
unless they make a commitment
to train somebody else.
It has to continue to go on.
That's level number four.
It's a beautiful level to be on.
It's the level where you develop people.